all right new five-minute game against
the International Master go on yeah
played him already a couple of times so
rated 2500 something pretty a pretty
strong good player and also the kind of
person will play on record is rook
without any parts so um it's um yeah hey
no comment mm-hmm all right we cut
another groom found again some some rail
line with Bishop t2 and stuff like this
so um what now you five need to need to
do this I think
yeah interesting interesting position
what should I should like do I could
play for c6 then it will have d6 and i'm
not sure if I I'll be able to to get to
this pawn maybe ok I could also maybe
this night this night to do six yeah I
could I could play a five year but down
the issue is that you might get a piece
to see five maybe I can play them p 6
okay it's a maybe strategically um
unproblematic but
Oh instantly I'm goes for some
countermeasures on the Kings side very
very sharp position at least I've got a
nice square on f4 all right what about
night h3 and h4 is this ridiculous
probably it is how do I get maybe his
ideas tonight a form move like b5 food
we can see five very very very immensely
I don't think this is good right let's
try to pile up on now the F file
yeah of course but it's not quite sure
that as that is only this Bishop it's
not a typical Kings Indian position
where I need this to to open it up y'all
often need to keep the white square
Bishop in the Kings Indian to have those
points of points the g4 it's not not
clear that i still need this all right
maybe we should to h6 cm okay cannot
enter on c7 yeah okay
yeah exactly in this position take with
the rock now rocks e7 how take the
ponies got e5 check your eyes he's
always playing for this those tricks
he's the kind of player yeah and now I'm
bishop age three to come yeah I am just
playing for tricks but is also playing
good ok let's try to prevent this Bishop
move
okay he might take them what about
Bishop to g5 to d8 I need to speed up
here as mentioned you will play for time
in any position so he's also quick
though um just telling that you get low
on time yeah it's not time not exactly a
comfortable position Bishop d8 still
yeah Queen g8 is also a possible problem
hi morning yeah this is so maybe our
Bishop age 3 also know or you really
outplayed me here are too hard to
believe that I could hold this only
hoping if he plays it really badly to
get some cement game oh he actually
allows this may be one just wants to win
on time but this justice wasn't the best
best way to play it one hundred percent
ok
yeah now we will play this on time of
course it's it's just nothing okay I can
always blunder you can almost always
plan and now i can even get the edge
pawn
dra honored it's not even trying
pretending to do anything this is not
completely dead
grah offered yeah as mentioned he's an
idiot what come okay you do yeah I
didn't pay any attention it's it's just
yeah I could also just resign it's just
it just isn't any fun to to play against
those idiots all right black resigns
okay let's hope for some other opponent
next game